In the name of the Father and of the Son and of the Holy Spirit, Amen.
The reading from the Sinaxadion, per September 5th, on which we commemorate, saints Zacharias
the Prophet and Elizabeth, the parents of the Forerunner.
On the 5th of the month we celebrate the memory of the Holy and Glorious Prophet Zacharias,
Father of Saint John the Baptist and Forerunner.
Zacharias was a Levite, descended from the High Priest, a Biyathar, and lived in Jerusalem
with his wife Elizabeth of the lineage of Aaron.
They were both righteous and observed all the commandments of the Lord with love, but had
remained childless until their old age.
It happened on the great holy day of the atonement that Zacharias to fulfill his
ministration as High Priest had gone alone into the sanctuary to burn incense when the
Archangel Gabriel appeared to him, standing on the right side of the altar of incense.
Shining with the divine light, the angel told him that God had heard his prayers and those
of his wife Elizabeth, and that he had granted them a son in their old age, who was to be
called John.
He will be filled with the Holy Spirit, even from his mother's womb, the angel announced,
and will go before the Lord to make ready a people prepared for him.
Zacharias was amazed at this vision and wondered whether to believe what he heard, so the angel
took away his power of speech until the birth of the Forerunner in order to teach him not
to doubt divine promises that surpass the order of nature.
Zacharias regained his speech on the day of the child's birth while he was writing the
name John on a tablet, and full of the Holy Spirit, he intoned the prophetic canticle.
Blessed be the Lord God of Israel, for he has visited and redeemed his people, and has raised
up a horn of salvation for us in the house of his servant David, as he spoke by the mouth
of his holy prophets from of old, and you, child, will be called the prophet of the most
high, for you will go before the Lord to prepare his ways, to give knowledge of salvation to
his people in the forgiveness of their sins.
Through the tender mercy of our God, when the day shall dawn upon us from on high, to give
light to those who sit in darkness and in the shadow of death, to guide our feet into
the way of peace.
After the birth of Christ, Zacharias plainly declared the virginity of Mary and showed her
truly to be the mother of God, for he appointed her a place in that part of the temple, reserved
for the virgins, and so brought upon himself the hatred of the priests and Levites.
When John was six months old, Zacharias hid him and his mother in a cave beyond the Jordan,
because King Herod, hearing of the birth in Bethlehem of the King of the Jews, and fearing
a rival of his own worldly power, sent soldiers to kill all the male children of Bethlehem.
His enemies seized this opportunity to denounce Zacharias to Herod, who had him pursued, and
put to death within the precinct of the temple, at the very place where the mother of God
abode for a witness to her virginity.
As the prophets blood flowed within the sanctuary, it signified the withdrawing of the divine
presence.
Priests came to take up his body, and they buried him with his fathers.
From that moment signs and prodigies occurred in the temple, indicating that the rights of
the law would soon be abolished.
No longer would the priests behold the angels of God, or have the grace of prophecy.
No longer would they be able to deliver oracles, or enlighten the people upon the dark places
of Holy Scripture, as they had been wont to do.
Through the prayers of our Holy Father's, O Lord, Jesus Christ our God, have mercy on us,
and save us.